l'ordre du jour appelle la discussion de
la proposition de résolution tendant à
la création d'une commission d'enquête
sur le modèle économique des entreprise
de crèche et la qualité de l'accueil des
jeunes enfants au sein de leurs
établissements la parole est à Monsieur
William Martiny rapporteur de la
commission des affaires
[Applaudissements]
sociales
bonjour
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés j'ai la charge de
vous présenter cette proposition de
résolution visant à créer une commission
d'enquête parlementaire sur le modèle
économique des crèches et la qualité
d'accueil des jeunes enfants vous
noterez que le périmètre de cette comm
mission d'enquête a évolué depuis son
passage en commission des finances en
effet il ne s'agit plus simplement
d'enquêter sur les entreprises de crèche
mais d'aborder le modèle économique de
toutes les crèches quel que soi leur
gestionnaire public associatif ou privé
lucratif cet élargissement permis par
l'adoption d'amendement du groupe les
républicains illustre le caractère
transpartisan de la commission d'enquête
c'est une évolution positive qui nous
donnera davantage de Marg de manœuvre
pour remplir l'objectif qui doit tous
nous rassembler défendre l'intérêt des
enfants accueillir un enfant dans une
crèche cela implique de répondre à ses
besoins premiers alimentation hygiène
sommeil mais la recherche scientifique
nous a amené ces dernières années à une
prise de conscience les besoins des
enfants sont infiniment complexes les
professionnels doivent assurer la
sécurité physique mais aussi affective
des enfants et leur offrir un cadre qui
permet leur développement garantir la
qualité de l'accueil des enfants dans
une crèche c'est en résumé construire un
environnement protecteur et bienveillant
dans lequel leurs besoins sont une
priorité la question qui se pose à nous
est donc la suivante le modèle
économique des crèche c'est-à-dire leur
financement l'organisation du travail en
leur sein et le cas échéant la recherche
de rentabilité tout cela permet-il de
garantir un tel environnement protecteur
et bienveillant malheureusement le doute
et l'inquiétude règne nous gardons en
mémoire le décès d'une petite fille en
juin 2022 dans une microocèche du groupe
people and baby cet événement dramatique
et on l'espère exceptionnel a libéré la
parole les témoignages des parents et
des professionnels se sont accumulé et
Ligas en a tiré un rapport accablant
chacun a pu prendre conscience de
l'existence d'une maltraitance
institutionnelle qui repose sur le
déniis du besoin des
enfants je parle du non respect du
rythme des bébés qui n'est pas
compatible avec les cadences infernales
les soins prodigués à la chaîne
l'organisation quasi industrielle du
travail dans certains état établissement
je parle du non respect du besoin de
référence c'est-à-dire la construction
du lien affectif entre l'adulte et
l'enfant qui l'accueille un lien
impossible à mettre en œuvre lorsque les
professionnels sont précaires
interchangeables et soumis à un
important turnover ce dont je voudrais
vous convaincre chers collègues c'est
que la maltraitance ne tombe pas du ciel
elle ne peut non plus se résumer à une
succession d'erreur individuelle ou
d'actes malveillant elle trouve son
origine dans le modèle économique des
crèches rappelons les sources de
financement d'un établissement d'accueil
de jeunes enfants d'abord les frais
d'inscription payés par les parents
parfois prohibitifs surtout lorsque nous
parlons de microocesche ensuite le
financement de la CAF que certains
comparent à la tarification à l'acte du
milieu hospitalier car il pousse de la
même façon à faire du chiffre au
détriment de la qualité et enfin le
tiers financeur le plus souvent la
commune pour qui la petite enfance n'est
pas une compétence et qui ne dispose pas
de financement dédiés et dont les
budgets sont déjà exanges le corollaire
de la faiblesse de ses financements
c'est la difficulté à proposer des
salaires attractifs pour recruter des
professionnels qualifiés le métier est
aussi exigeant que les rémunérations
sont faibles la plupart des
professionnels sont osmiqu et même les
plus diplômés d'entre elles éducatrices
de jeunes enfants ou infirmière
puricultrice commencent leur carrière à
peine plus haut que le salaire minimum
voilà pourquoi le secteur est confronté
à une grave pénurie selon la CAF 10000
places sont fermées faute de
professionnels mais au-delà des places
fermées il faut imaginer la souffrance
qui existe dans un collectif de travail
mis en tension par le sous-effectif le
sentiment de ne pas faire son travail
correctement la culpabilité de prendre
des jours des congés ou d'être en arrêt
maladie l'épuisement professionnel qui
parfois se traduit en burnout voilà plus
d'une décennie que la réponse politique
à la pénurie a principalement consisté à
baisser les exigences de qualification
des professionnels ce mouvement de
dérégulation a aggravé le problème qu'il
prétendait traiter moins les
professionnels sont qualifiés et
nombreuses plus les conditions de
travail se dégrade l'attractivité du
métier n'a malheureusement jamais été
aussi faible alors résumons d'un côté
des financements insuffisant de l'autre
une pénurie de professionnels qualifiés
il paraît donc difficilement contestable
que le modèle économique des crèches est
à revoir il produit une qualité
d'accueil des enfants que l'IGAS a
pudiquement qualifié
d'hétérogène en d'autres termes il n'est
pas possible de garantir que partout
quoi qu'il arrive les enfants soient
bien traités et ce constat en tant que
parlementaire devrait suffire pour nous
pousser à
agir s'ajoute à cette difficulté
générale l'enjeu spécifique du secteur
privé lucratif qui n'est plus l'unique
objet de cette commission d'enquête mais
qui n'en a pas disparu pour autant il y
a 20 ans a été créé un système très
avantageux pour les opérateurs privés
notamment grâce à un crédit d'impôt
dédié le très mal nommé crédit d'impôt
famille alors qu'il bénéficie
essentiellement aux grandes entreprises
certains parlent d'un un business
bibronné à l'argent public liigas évoque
plus plus sobrement un surcalibrage des
financements publics le privé lucratif
est aujourd'hui hyper développé il
représente 80 % des ouvertures de
crèches ces 10 dernières années hyper
concentrés quatre grands groupes gèrent
les tr/4 des berceaux privés et hyper
financiarisés car les grands groupes
sont contrôlés par des fonds
d'investissement les fonds
d'investissement dont nous parlons sont
capitalisés à hauteur de plusieurs
milliards d'euros ils ont dans leur
portefeuille aussi bien des crèches en
France que des pipelines en mer du Nord
de la fibre optique au Pays-Bas ou des
lignes ferroviaires en Italie il faut
donc bien comprendre que les
établissements des grands groupes malgré
leur nom chaleureux les clochettes la
maison des kangourous lapin et compagnie
sont soumis à de froides exigences de
rentabilité de la part des investisseurs
et cette financiarisation indéiablement
a produit des dérives dans l'ouvrage le
prix du berceau des journalistes Daphné
Gastaldi et Matthieu Peris nous
apprenons qu'un de ces grands groupes
les Petits Chaperons Rouges a mis en
place un système de prime encourant
encourageant à faire des économie sur
l'alimentation des tout petits résultat
dans certaines crèches le nombre de
repas commandés était inférieur au
nombre de bébés inscrits les directions
d'établissement misant sur une absence
habituelle d'un certain nombre d'enfants
et quand par malheur il n'y avait pas
d'absent tant pis les portions étaient
divisées et les enfants ne mangeaient
pas à leur fin chers collègues qui peut
rester sans réaction face à ces dérives
les alertes d'ailleurs nous viennent de
partout je cite Ligas la régulation
insuffisante du secteur marchand a
laisser prospérer des stratégies
économiques préjudiciables à la qualité
de l'accueil je cite l'Union nationale
des associations familial voyant rouge
sur le modèle économique des crèches
privées lucratives je pourrais encore
citer le Haut Conseil de l'enfance de la
famille et de l'âge l'UFC Que Choisir ou
le collectif pas de bébé à la consigne
tous à leur façon demandent que que la
lumière soit faite sur ce
système le risque quel est-il que se
produis dans la petite enfance les mêmes
dérive que dans le secteur des épades
tout le monde ici se souvient des
scandales Orpa et coriant et bien je
vous le dis il nous faut enquêter dès
aujourd'hui pour éviter qu'éclate demain
un scandale qui serait en quelque sorte
le or pa de la petite enfance parce que
maintenant nous n'avons plus l'excuse de
l'ignorance nous sommes informés des
risques de la financiarisation du
médico-social nous savons que les les
problèmes spécifiques posés par la
cohabitation entre lucrativité et prise
en charge de public vulnérable nous
savons que la puissance publique doit
prendre ses
responsabilités quand je parle de
prendre nos responsabilités qu'on se
comprenne bien chers collègues je ne
vous demande pas en votant sur
l'opportunité de cette commission
d'enquête de vous prononcer pour ou
contre l'ouvertur aux acteurs privé du
secteur de la petite enfance sur ce
point de vue vous connaissez la position
de mon groupe parlementaire les insoumis
considère que certains âges de la vie de
la petite enfance et du grand âge
certaines activités sociales l'éducation
le soin devrait être préservé de la
recherche de lucrativité mais vous
pouvez penser le contraire vous pouvez
penser qu'une meilleure régulation du
secteur privé serait une réponse
suffisante ce que nous vous demandons à
travers ce vote c'est d'entendre les
alertes qui ont été émises d'entendre
qu'il y a eu des dérives dans ce système
et de donner à la représentation
nationale les moyens d'enquêter pour
pouvoir enfin agir je vais même
m'adresser à ceux qui sont le plus
convaincus de la pertinence d'ouvrir la
petite enfance aux acteurs privés
lucratifs finalement de quoi avez-vous
peur votez pour cette commission
d'enquête et vous pourrez ensuite y
participer y défendre votre point de vue
cette commission d'enquête sera composée
à la proportionnelle des groupes de
l'Assemblée nationale les auditions
seront publiques il faudrait que
finalement vos convictions soient bien
fragiles pour qu'ell craignne le débat
argumenté d'une commission
d'enquête je tiens à vous dire que cette
commission d'enquête est très attendue
que nos débats sont particulièrement
observés je pense aux parents des 460000
enfants accueillis en crèche dont
l'inquiétude est grandissante ils savent
que le le système dysfonctionne et qu'il
existe un risque pour leurs enfants ils
se posent alors des questions qu'aucun
parent ne devrait se poser mon enfant
a-t-il mangé à sa fin d'où viennent les
équimoses retrouvés sur son bras les
professionnels ont eu le temps de lui
donner à boire et de lui changer sa
couche face à ces inquiétudes les
parents sont pour l'instant bien seuls
il est parfois difficile de se faire
entendre d'une administration ou d'un
grand groupe privé prendre la parole en
public engager une procédure judiciaire
c'est prendre le risque d'une plainte en
représaille ou même tout simplement de
perdre la place qu'on a eu toutes les
difficultés du monde à trouver ces
parents méritent que nous soyons à leur
côté que nous mettions les moyens de
l'Assemblée nationale à leur disposition
pour obtenir la transparence et corriger
un système défaillant alors chers
collègues aujourd'hui par notre vote ne
donnons pas l'impression que nous
cherchons à enterrer un scandale à
éviter un sujet qui F ne donnons pas
l'impression que nous sommes les relais
d'un lobby ou d'intérêt privé et je sais
qu'ils se sont activés fortement en
coulisse assumons notre rôle de
parlementaire garant de l'intérêt
général quelque chose ne tourne pas rend
dans le monde des crèches l'intérêt des
enfants est en jeu alors
enquêtons merci monsieur le
rapporteur nous passons à la discussion
générale la parole est à Madame Anne St
terno pour groupe la France insoumise
[Applaudissements]
nupes
merci merci madame la présidente
monsieur le rapporteur chers collègues
aujourd'hui les jeunes parents de ce
pays nous regardent car nous avons
l'opportunité d'initier ensemble une
commission d'enquête parlementaire sur
le modèle économique des crèches et la
qualité de l'accueil des jeunes enfants
et je remercie mon collègue William
Martinet pour cette initiative salutaire
car voilà des années que les
professionnels du secteur de la petite
enfance nous alertent sur la dégradation
de leurs conditions de travail et donc
de la qualité de l'accueil des petits je
pense au collectif pas de bébé à la
consigne mobilisé depuis 2018 les
professionnels décrivent le manque de
personnel des taux d'encadrement
toujours plus insuffisants le recours à
du personnel peu qualifié ou encore la
possibilité d'accueillir des enfants en
surnombre une précarité entretenue et
des situations du quotidien qui
conduisent ces femmes car ce sont
majoritairement des femmes à
l'épuisement mais aussi au bord de
pratique qu'elle juge elle-même
potentiellement maltraitante jusqu'au
drame en juin 2022 une petite fille est
morte après qu'une employée de crèche
lui ait fait ingérer du desktop il a
fallu l'horreur la concrétisation du
pire cauchemar de tout parents qui
confie son enfant pour aller travailler
pour qu'enfin on entende et que
l'Inspection générale des affaires
sociales enquête et alerte à son son
tour les pouvoirs publics sur
l'existence d'une maltraitance
institutionnelle dans les crèches de
notre pays une maltraitance
institutionnelle la première fois que
j'ai entendu ce terme c'était lors du
scandale Orpa lorsque j'ai écouté comme
beaucoup d'entre vous des aides
soignantes en larme parler de leurs
conditions de travail en épade et du
sentiment de ne plus pouvoir sous la
pression exercer leur métier dignement
de se sentir inhumaine car maltraitante
alors que leur volonté première était au
contraire de prendre soin et la France
découvrait effaré les économies faites
sur les repas les protection hygiénique
les soins chronométrés irréalisables
dans le temps imparti l'impossibilité de
prendre le temps de parler écouter en
bref le porte-monnaie comme maître du
temps or nos tout jeunes enfants ont
ceci en commun avec nos anciens qu'ils
sont dépendants de nous pour leur
bien-être comme pour leur survie et deux
édifiantes enquêtes journalistiques
révèlent des pratiques tout aussi
inquiétantes pour les petits dans
certaines crèches des repas rationnés et
insuffisants des enfants qui restent
dans leur couche sououillé toute la
journée leur rythme de sommeil perturbé
et bien sûr trop peu de profess
professionnel épuisé physiquement comme
psychiquement face à des enfants trop
nombreux mes chers collègues je crois
que la façon dont nous prenons soin de
ceux qui sont en situation de dépendance
dit beaucoup de nous c'est une question
de santé publique mais aussi une vraie
question morale quelle société
voulons-nous être et nous parlementaires
que faisons-nous pour empêcher les
dérives pour protéger les plus
fragiles les 1000 premiers jours de vie
d'un citoyen français sont décisifs sur
le plan affectif sur le plan cognitif
c'est là qu'on construit parfois le pire
et qu'on peut batt ti le meilleur ce
n'est pas de moi mais d'Emmanuel Macron
le 25 avril 2019 et en effet la
recherche en neurologie montre que la
petite enfance est une période clé dans
le développement cérébral émotionnel et
social c'est de cela que nous parlons
aujourd'hui alors soyons à la
hauteur la pression est énorme pour les
parents son mode de garde c'est
l'impossibilité de travailler pour au
moins un d'entre eux bien souvent la
merère avec tout ce que cela implique en
terme de précarité pour la famille
surtout si elle est monoparental les
places manque dans les crèches en
particulier public poussant les parents
à se rabattre sur les crèches privées
alors comme la demande est supérieure à
l'offre certains ont bien perçu une m
financière derrière cette mission de
service public des établissements privés
imposent des prix exorbitants couplés à
des logiques de rentabilité à l'excès le
tout encouragé par l'État lui-même à
coup d'aide au financement et de crédit
d'impôt ces 10 dernières années 80 % des
berceaux ont été ouverts par des
entreprises de crèche pour l'essentiel
adossé à des fonds d'investissement or
le dernier rapport de l'Inspection
générale des affaires sociales nous
apprend que l'arrivée de ces fonds
d'investissement au capital des
entreprises de crèche coïncide avec une
politique de compression de la masse
salariale autrement dit on économise sur
les rémunérations et les embauches pour
maximiser les marges au détriment des
enfants alors oui il y a urgence à
enquêter sur le modèle économique des
crèches et sur leurs conséquences sur
les conditions d'accueil de nos enfants
en commission le périmètre de l'enquête
a été élargi à tout types de crèches et
bien tant mieux collègues enquêtons
ensemble notre rôle est de contrôler
l'action publique et l'utilisation des
fonds publics voilà une belle occasion
transpartisane d'utiliser nos
prérogatives pour l'intérêt général face
aux multiples alertes les parents et
futurs parents de ce pays ne comprendrai
pas un recul de notre assemblée et pour
nos collègues qui prétendent légiférer
avant mais oui agissons rien ne nous
empêche de légiférer dès maintenant mais
enquêtons aussi pour mieux agir encore
voez cette commission d'enquête votez
pour les professionnels de la petite
enfance pour les parents pour vos
enfants vos petits-enfants vos neveux ou
pour ce bébé croisé dans le métro qui a
illuminé votre journée par son sourire
ensemble assurons-nous qu'il ne soit pas
ou plus permis de faire des économies
qui menaceraient notre plus grande
richesse notre avenir littéralement nos
tout petits je vous
merci merci madame la
députée la parole est à Monsieur thibaau
Bazin pour le groupe les
républicains
merci madame la présidente madame la
présidente de la commission des affaires
sociales monsieur le rapporteur mes
chers collègues nous voici réunis pour
examiner votre proposition de résolution
visant à la création d'une commission
d'enquête sur le modèle économique des
entreprises de crèche et la qualité de
l'accueil des jeunes enfants au sein de
leurs établissements les mots on un sens
il me semble important d'approfondir ce
que vous vous avez utilisé monsieur le
rapporteur afin de mieux comprendre
l'esprit qui vous anime vous souhaitez
dévoiler je cite le caractère
institutionnel de la maltraitance et le
système économique où celle-ci trouve
son origine vous parlez de
marchandisation du secteur de la petite
enfance décidé à bas bruit en 2004 vous
remettez en cause des décisions
politiques prises il y a 20 ans vous
remettez en cause l'accès des acteurs
privés aux subventions de fonctionnement
et d'investissement de la caisse
d'allocation familiale vous remettez
même en cause la délégation de service
public en soi
mais mais les crèches privées
n'ont-elles pas besoin d'un agrément de
la PMI pour fonctionner mais les crèches
privées n'ont-elles pas besoin de
remplir des obligations pour recevoir
ces fonds publics de la CAF ces
décisions prises il y a 20 ans que vous
dénoncez n'ont-elles pas permis de
développer des solutions de garde
collectif pour les parents qui en
avaient besoin vous souhaitez qu'on crée
une commission d'enquête et qu'on vous
confie la mission de la rapporter mais
quand on enquête on pose des questions
or là vous semblez avoir condamné déjà
par avance tout un secteur dans son
ensemble en procédant par affirmation
globalisante plutôt que par
questionnement oui à des enquêtes pour
identifier les dysfonctionnements et y
remédier mais non au présupposer que
tout acteur privé serait malinttentionné
et ne pourrait pas gérer un service
public en assurant la qualité d'accueil
des enfants en France aujourd'hui
plusieurs dizaines de milliers de places
de crèche sont gérées par des acteurs
privés elles répondent à des besoins des
familles certains s'inscrivent même dans
des délégations de service public conçu
et suivi avec attention par des
collectivité locale compétente en
matière de petite enfance des milliers
de professionnels qualifiés s'y
impliquent avec dévouement au service
des enfants qui leur sont confiés je
souhaite saluer leur engagement car
certains mots prononcés ont pu les
blesser injustement bien sûr comme dans
tout secteur professionnel il peut
exister des dysfonctionnements il faut
les reconnaître et travailler sans
relâche pour les corriger mais on ne
peut laisser penser que les acteurs
privés ne seraient pas contrôlés la
Protection Maternelle et Infantile suit
toutes les structure quel que soit leur
statut les contrôles de la PMI sont
réguliers et leurs recommandations sont
exigeantes pour l'obtention d'agrément
de 100 côté la caisse deallocation
familiale veille aux actions menées lié
au versement de prestation le suivi
financier et comptable est lui aussi
exigeant on ne peut pas laisser dire que
toute gestion du service public de la
petite enfance par des acteurs privés
serait en soi porteuse de maltraitance
et synonyme de détournement de fonds
publics ces insinuations sont graves
nous ne partageons pas votre philosophie
monsieur le rapporteur les collectivités
locales font parfois le choix quand cela
leur semble pertinent et cela relève de
leur libre administration de déléguer le
service public de la petite enfance par
la gestion multiaccueil à des acteurs
privés déléguer ne signifie pas ne pas
contrôler d'ailleurs les cahiers des
charges conçus par les élus peuvent être
exigeants et promouvoir des innovations
qualitatives les acteurs privés ont pu
créer des places dont les familles de
France ont besoin il serait injuste de
les condamner juste à de leur statut
privé cela étant dit la qualité
d'accueil des jeunes enfants au sein des
crèches haltegarderie et multiaccueil
nous préoccupe des drames que vous avez
cité appellent une vigilance redoublée
des pouvoirs publics nous tenons
d'ailleurs à saluer l'engagement continu
des collectivités de la PMI de la CAF et
de tous les acteurs impliqués pour
l'améliorer cela passe par des bâtiments
adaptés cela passe également par des
équipes mieux formées cela passe enfin
par une gouvernance qui a associe les
partenaires et les parents à
l'évaluation continue de la qualité
d'accueil de bonnes pratiques existent
déjà dans le public comme dans le privé
œuvrons à les diffuser à les promouvoir
car c'est bien en valorisant ce service
de qualité qu'on assurera l'attractivité
de ce secteur et les besoins en
recrutement sont importants ce sont
toutes les raisons pour lesquelles nous
nous opposerons à cette proposition de
résolution en l'état qui condamne à
priori toute gestion privée d'un service
public mettant dans le même sac tout un
secteur alors qu'il ne faut pas
généraliser des dysfonctionnements dont
nous ne nions pas l'existence et auquel
il faut remédier avec détermination
soyons exigeant envers tous les acteurs
de la petite enfance quel que soit leur
statut car les enfants représentent
l'avenir de notre nation nous devons les
protéger et leur permettre de grandir
dans les meilleures conditions les
enfants dont les parents font le choix
de confier la garde à des structures
d'accueil collectif doivent être ainsi
bien accueillis dans de bonnes
conditions à tous ceux qui travaillent
en ce sens partenair comme
professionnels nous leur adressons nos
encouragements à poursuivre avec
détermination dans cette voix et nous
leur exprimons notre sincère
reconnaissance car leur métier a du sens
au service des enfants les parents on
besoin d'eux la France a besoin d'eux
merci monsieur le
député la parole est à Madame pine Goul
pour le groupe démocrate modem et
[Applaudissements]
indépendant
madame la présidente madame la
présidente de la commission des affaires
sociales chers collègues nous examinons
aujourd'hui l'opportunité de la création
d'une commission d'enquête sur le modèle
économique des crèches et la qualité de
l'accueil des jeunes enfants au sein de
leur établissement si un tel sujet
semble être louable il apparaît que
malgré un titre alléchant le contenu n'y
est pas et qui plus est le sujet est à
contreemp permettez-moi tout d'abord de
vous rappeler que depuis 1 an
l'Assemblée nationale dispose d'une
délégation aux droits des enfants qui
s'est saisie de plusieurs sujet et
notamment celui qui nous intéresse
aujourd'hui en effet nous avons mené un
cycle d'audition en début d'année sur ce
sujet nous avons auditionné le ministre
d'Alor Jean-Christophe combe
l'association des mairres de France la
Caissse d'allocation familial les
syndicats et Fédération des
professionnel de la petite enfance et
Ligas qui a rendu un rapport très
complet démontrant la nécessité d'agir
d'ailleurs bien avant les livres
polémiques devant cette urgence à agir
en faveur de l'intérêt supérieur de
l'enfant nous avons délé à deux
collègues Michel Peron Isabelle Santiago
la mission de faire rapidement des
propositions au regard de leur
connaissance préalable du sujet et après
de nombreuses auditions elles ont rendu
leur rapport axé sur les perspectives
d'évolution de la prise en charge des
enfants dans les crèches et uniquement
sous le prisme du bien-être des enfants
je tiens d'ailleurs à les remercier une
nouvelle fois pour ce travail de grande
qualité monsieur le rapporteur dans ce
que vous proposez vous portez une
accusation à charge à l'endroit des
crèches votre rôle dans dans
l'opposition est forcément plus simple
puisqu'il suffit de dire que ce qui ne
va pas c'est de la faute du gouvernement
et de la majorité présidentielle notre
rôle dans la majorité c'est de ne pas
céder à la facilité et de faire avec le
réel et de tenter de l'améliorer je dis
tenter car nous devons avoir la modestie
de penser que la loi ne peut pas tout
alors voilà pour la forme sur le fond
mon inquiétude est double tout d'abord à
lire votre document il apparaît que vos
conclusions sont déjà faites pour s'en
convaincre l'exposer des motifs de votre
proposition de résolution
vous avez déjà les conclusions en
caricaturant à peine les entreprises
c'est mal dans ce que vous nous proposer
nous ne risquons pas d'apprendre
grand-chose comme cela a déjà été le cas
dans votre commission d'enquête uber F
qui a fait sheit nous disposons de tous
les documents et rapports nécessaires
pour améliorer les conditions d'accueil
des tout petits je pense au rapport de
l'UNAF je pense au rapport de l'Igas je
pense au rapport sur les PMI de notre
collègue Michel perron et je pense
évidemment au rapport de la délégation
sur le sujet une commission d'enquête ne
ferait que retarder les actions qui
pourraent être mises en pratique nous
pourrions nous concentrer plutôt sur les
recommandations émises par notre rapport
d'information qui ont été formulé dans
l'unique intérêt des enfants et que
vous-même monsieur Martinet vous avez
reconnu comme bonne ce rapport
d'information apporte également des
éléments que vous n'évoquez même pas la
prise en compte des avancées des
neurosciences dans le domaine de
l'accueil du jeune enfant les besoins
spécifiques des enfants en basage ont
mieux compris et est impératif
d'intégrer ses connaissances dans nos
politiques publiques ignorer ces
avancées reviendrait à négliger les
fondements même du développement de nos
enfants la mission flash a par ailleurs
énoncé plusieurs mesures cruciales
telles que l'interdiction pure et simple
des formations CAP petite enfance en
ligne ou encore la nécessité de revoir
le décret Morano qui a diminué les
exigences de l'effectif moyen annuel des
professionnels chargé de l'encadrement
des enfants je reprends également la
recommandation de calculer le taux
d'encadrement au niveau niveau des
sections et groupes d'enfants et non au
niveau de l'établissement afin de gagner
bien entendu en attractivité par
l'amélioration des conditions de travail
notamment matériel nous appuyons
également la préconisation de Ligas de
définir une trajectoire pour se
rapprocher d'un ratio moyen
d'encadrement de 5 enfants par adulte
pour toutes ces raisons la CRÉ la
création de cette commission d'enquête
n'est pas nécessaire en effet les quatre
premiers alignéés à proposer ne nous
permettront en aucun cas d'améliorer
concrètement la situation des enfants en
crèche c'est simplement une acquisition
que vous menez et c'est visiblement
votre but incriminer les responsables de
crèche concernant les deux derniers
alinéas les principales recommandations
de la mission flash portant sur les
crèches dégation au droits des enfants y
répondent amplement ce dont nous avons
besoin ce sont des actions concrètes
basées sur les recommandations de la
mission flash de l déégation au droits
des enfants afin d'améliorer la qualité
de l'accueil des jeunes enfants dans nos
crèches enfin comme vous le savez la
ligne du groupe modem sur les
commissions d'enquête est claire elles
doivent être limitées au droit de tirage
annuel alors messieurs mesdames plutôt
que de perdre du temps dans la
réalisation d'une commission d'enquête
qui nous apprendra rien de plus que ce
que nous connaissons et rien de concret
sur la prise en charge sur le terrain
des enfants construisons ensemble un
texte portant les avancées dont tout le
secteur a besoin parce que c'est ça
l'urgence et pas une commission
d'enquête bref vous l'avez compris le
groupe démocrate votera contre cette
proposition de création de commission
r merci Madame la député la parole est à
Monsieur JO avirag pour le groupe
socialiste et
[Applaudissements]
apparenté merciadame la présid madame la
Présidente de la Commission monsieur le
rapporteur mes chers
collègues nous avons tous été choqués
par le rapport de Ligas les deux
enquêtes qui on démontrer les graves
défaillances du modèle économique des
crèches la proposition de notre collègue
Martinet portant sur la création d'une
commission d'enquête sur ce sujet reçoit
tout notre soutien en effet il est
intolérable que les premiers mois de vie
de nos enfants souffr de la cupidité de
certains groupes privés prêt à tout pour
réaliser toujours plus de
profit alors que 80 % des crèches
privées à but lucratif sont détenus par
quatre FO investissement il est logique
que l'accueil des enfants empâtisse
c'est pourquoi nous devons enquêter
enquêter d'abord pour constater l'étendu
de ces dérives enquêter ensuite pour
réfléchir collectivement aux
modifications législatives que nous
pourons apporter pour garantir un
accueil digne et humain dans toutes les
crèches nous le devons à nos enfants
nous devons les protéger permettre leur
épanouissement et leur bonne santé il
est dommageable que les périmètres de
cette commission d'enquête é été élarg
dénaturant ainsi la proposition initiale
cependant la situation est bien trop
grave pour
pinailler comme ma collègue Isabelle
Santiago dans son rapport je souhaite un
renforcement des contrôles des crèches
privées à but lucratif nous devons aussi
urgemment repenser leur modèle
économique afin d'empêcher toutes
dérivve qui placeraient l'intérêts des
enfants après la recherche du permanente
du profit financier plus largement nous
députés socialistes souhaitons repenser
le mode de fonctionnement du secteur de
la petite enfance si les crèches public
comme privé manque de personnel c'est à
cause de rémunération indigne au vu de
l'importance du travail effectué c'est
également dû à une perte de sens du
travail qui frappe tout le secteur du
médicosocial et plus largement de
nombreux métiers essentiels en notre
nation nous refusons cette société où le
profit financier passe avant le
bien-être et avant la santé pour nos
anciens comme pour nos enfants nous
voulons un accueil digne un
environnement sain et des personnels qui
travaillent dans de bonnes conditions
nous voterons donc pour cette
proposition de résolution visant à créer
une commission d'enquête parlementaire
sur le modèle économique des crèches et
la maltraitance institutionnelle dans
ses établissements je vous remercie
merci monsieur le député la parole est à
Monsieur Frédéric Valtou pour le groupe
horizon et
apparenté madame la
présidente monsieur le rapporteur madame
la présidente de la commission des
affaires sociales mais mes chers
collègues cette demande d'une commission
d'enquête parait mal et nous l'avons dit
lors de la commission mais le sujet est
suffisamment important que pour ne pas y
réfléchir à deux fois et c'est dans cet
état d'esprit que le groupe horizon
étudiaé la la proposition qui était
faite par vous monsieur le rapporteur
initialement nous l'avions dit en
commission son libélé son objet et et la
manière dont elle était présentée était
effectivement caricaturale mais la
Commission a travaillé a voté les
amendements et aujourd'hui l'affaire est
tout autre d'abord avant d'y revenir je
voudrais ajouter queelle se situe dans
un contexte qu'il est nécessaire selon
moi de de rappeler il faut pas oublier
que la refond fondation la politique
d'accueil du jeune enfant a vu ses
premiers jalons posés lors du précédent
quinquena et je pense en particulier au
plan rebond petit enfance qui a été
d'une ampleur sans précédent en matière
d'aide à l'investissement et au
développement de l'offre d'accueil et à
la démarche des 1000 premiers jours qui
visent à lutter contre les inégalités de
destin en créant des conditions
favorables au développement de de
l'enfant et le travail ne s'est pas
arrêté là un rapport de Ligas commandé
par le ministère des solidarités des
familles a fait un état des lieux sur la
qualité de l'accueil et de la
bientraitance des enfants accueillis en
crèche et a fait la lumière sur les
éventuelles fragilités du système rendu
public en avril dernier celui-ci a émis
39 recommandations pour accompagner la
montée en qualité du secteur et
renforcer sa capacité à répondre
pleinement aux besoins des enfants ce
rapport révèle que plusieurs progrès ont
été réalisés en ce sens dès la
précédente mandature comme l'institution
d'une gouvernance locale de l'accueil du
du jeune enfant dans le cadre des
comités départementaux des services aux
familles et la mise en place d'un
référentiel national pour l'aménagement
intérieur des crèches une première
campagne ambitieuse de valorisation des
métiers de la petite enfance a également
été lancée pour rendre hommage au
travail quotidien de ces professionnels
de la petite enfance qui joue un rôle
crucial pour les enfants leur famille et
plus globalement pour la cohésion
sociale il nous faut les valoriser
davantage bien sûr d'autre part le plan
pour garantir un meilleur accueil du
jeune enfant annoncé par la première
ministre à l'été dernier prévoit de
dégager une enveloppe de 5,5 milliards
d'euros pour la création de 200000
places supplémentaires englobant à la
fois des places en crèche et des et des
assistantes maternelle alors oui notre
majorité présidentielle agit en menant
une politique familiale volontarisse
pour toutes et tous adaptés aux
évolutions de la société et aux attentes
des parents pour offrir à chacun les
solutions dont ils ont besoin plus
récemment encore dans le projet de loi
pour le plein emploi qui a été adopté
définitivement il y a quelques jours
nous avons créé le service public de la
petite enfance cette mesure constitue
une avancé importante et met en œuvre un
engagement majeur du président de la
République garantir l'accueil de de
chaque jeune enfant quel que soit son
lieu de naissance ou de vie une hausse
de salaire des professionnels de la
petite enfance du secteur public est
également prévue dans le projet de loi
de financement de la Sécurité sociale
pour 2024 avec 200 millions d'euros qui
accompagneront chaque année les
revalorisations ils pourront atteindre
10 % moyenne pour les auxiliaires de
puriculture comme vous l'avez annoncé
madame la ministre qui n'est pas là mais
qui aait je pensais qu'elle était là
comme vous l'avez annoncé madame la
ministre pas 1 € de cet argent n'ira aux
structures qui n'amélioreraient pas
réellement les conditions de travail des
professionnels de la petite enfance et
qui n'auraient pas d'engagement très
clair sur la qualité de l'accueil c'est
une mesure forte qui permettra de
responsabiliser les groupes à la fois
public et privé par ailleurs deux de nos
collègues Michel perron et et Isabelle
Santiago ont su faire œuvre utile à
travers leurs travaux sur la mission
flash portant sur les perspectives
d'évolution de la prise en charge des
enfants dans les crèches s'agissant la
proposition de de résolution qui nous
qui nous est soumise aujourd'hui et qui
était à l'origine je le disais dans une
approche qui caricaturale car elle
ciblait et vous l'avez d'ailleurs
rappelé dans vos propos initiaux
monsieur le rapporteur uniquement le la
gestion privée dans une dans avec des
termes qui nous semblent effectivement
totalement inadaptés par rapport à ce qu
l'offre privée sur cette approche
uniquement centrée sur l'offre privée
notre groupe Horizon est été réservé je
était donc comme je le disais ouvert à
la commission mais à partir du moment où
l'objet de la de la Commission de la
commission d'enquête a été élargie à
l'ensemble des crèches de tous statut
nos nos appréhension ont été levé si le
groupe Horizon est apparenté sait qu'il
ne faut pas multiplier ce type de
procédure tendant à la création de
commission d'enquête pour recueillir des
éléments d'information puisqu'il
convient plutôt d'agir il considère
néanmoins comme utile la création de
d'une telle commission pour permettre
d'objectiver le débat et nous serons
vigilants que le travail d'enquête
parlementaire soit fait avec rigueur et
impartialité ETM ainsi sur le même pied
l'ensemble des acteurs de la petite
enfance c'est pour ça que nous voterons
la proposition de
résolution merci monsieur le député pour
la la bonne information de tout le monde
avant qu'il soit reproché quoi que ce
soit au gouvernement
une proposition de résolution surtout
demandant une commission d'enquête je
vous rappelle mes chers collègues que
les commissions d'enquête c'est une
décision interne au Parlement et donc le
gouvernement ne prend pas part aux
décisions internes de notre Parlement
d'où l'absence du gouvernement qui n'a
pas à interférer aux décisions que nous
prenons
ensemble la parole est à Madame
Marie-Charlotte Garin pour le groupe
écologiste
nupess mesdames les présidentes chers
collègues vous avez aimé le scandale des
épades voici celui des crèches mercredi
22 juin une fillette âgée de 11 mois est
morte empoisonnée dans une crèche privée
du 3e arrondissement de Lyon ce n'était
pas la première fois que l'entreprise
people et Baby était mentionné dans des
soupçons de maltraitance en décembre
2021 une famille avait porté plainte
pour cou et blessures sur une fillette
de 4 mois en février dernier des
salariés d'une autre crèche people et
Baby cette fois à Dijon se sont mis en
grève pour dénoncer les conditions
d'accueil des enfants de leur structure
température glaciale faute de chauffage
machine défectueuse matelas arraché et
j'en passe de quoi susciter l'inquiétude
de parents déjà stressés par le simple
fait de confier leur enfant et de
trouver un mode de garde car oui en
France aujourd'hui c'est encore la croix
et la bannière pour trouver des places
dans certains endroits on s'inscrit au
6e mois de grossesse parfois on s'entend
dire qu'on peut toujours s'inscrire ou
de ne pas hésiter à mettre une photo ou
à écrire une lettre pour son dossier et
chacun ici sait dans cet hémicycle
l'importance de la garde d'enfants
notamment pour l'égalité professionnelle
entre les femmes et les hommes dans son
rapport d'avril Ligas s'alarme d'une
qualité d'accueil très disparate au côté
de crèches de grande qualité portée par
une réflexion pédagogique approfondie on
trouve aussi des établissements de
qualité très dégradé ce qui peut
entraîner des carences dans la
sécurisation affective et dans l'é veill
des tout petits certains faits relatés
lors de l'enquête sont extrêmement
graves enfants oubliés sur les toilettes
privés de siestes faus de lit en nombre
suffisant ou au contraire laisser
ampleur jusqu'à ce qu'ils s'endorment
d'autres t toignages font état d'enfants
à qui on ne donne pas à boire comme ça
on change moins les couches qu'on laisse
trop longtemps dans leurs couches
souillé que l'on humilie ou insulte en
leur disant qu'ils chouinent pour rien
qu'ils sentent mauvais que l'on nourrit
de force en leur pinçant le nez pour
qu'ils ouvrent la bouche ou même que
l'on maltraite on maltraite physiquement
en leur tirant les cheveux aujourd'hui
80 % des nouvelles places de crèche
appartiennent au privés lucratif un
secteur en plein boom ça n'est pas
normal et je remercie mon collègue
William Martinet de nous permettre
aujourd'hui de mettre en lumière ce
système opaque et la privatisation une
fois de plus d'un service
public bien sûr la maltraitance n'est
pas l'apanage des crèches privées
partout des conditions de travail
dégradées peuvent mener à la
maltraitance d'où l'importance de les
améliorer et de ne pas se contenter de
se focaliser sur les contrôles au lieu
de cela le gouvernement n'a cessé de les
dégrader avec des arrêtés pour permettre
de recruter en crèche des personnes sans
qualification ni expérience avec la
baisse du taux d'encadrement cinq
enfants qui ne marchent pas encore pour
un professionnel c'est c'est indigne
c'est irresponsable et il faut que cela
change il est urgent de permettre aux
professionnels de la petite enfance
souvent des femmes souvent sousrémunéré
de pouvoir exercer leur métier dans les
meilleures conditions j'aimerais
conclure sur une autre préconisation de
Ligas qui rappelle que pour un bébé de
moins d'un an passer 40 heures par
semaine en crèche avec ce que cela
implique de bruit d'agitation de risque
de surstimulation n'est de toute façon
pas la réponse la plus adaptée à ses
besoins c'est pour cela que les
écologistes ont soutenu la création d'un
véritable service public de la petite
enfance depuis bien longtemps Liiga
s'appelle en conséquence à je cite
revoir la durée et les règles de
rémunération des congés maternels
paternels et parentaux pour accroître la
possibilité de présence parentale auprès
de l'enfant pendant la première année de
vie j'aimerais aujourd'hui remercier la
ville de Lyon qui vient de rallonger la
durée du congé paternité pour qu'il il
atteigne celle du congé maternité pour
ses agents heureusement que les villes
notamment écologistes n'attendent pas le
gouvernement pour agir et évidemment
nousous tenons à la disposition de la
majorité présidentielle pour
nationaliser ce dispositif je terminerai
enfin en saluant les échanges que nous
avons eu en commission des affaires
sociales ils ont permis d'élargir le
périmètre de la commission d'enquête
pour prendre en compte les différentes
sensibilités sur ces bancs après ce
travail et cette recherche de consensus
il serait inaudible que notre assemblée
s'oppose à cette commission d'enquête et
je suis un peu surprise d'entendre sur
les bans de la majorité qu'on nous
demande qu'on nous dit qu'il ne faudrait
pas qu'il y ait plus de chiffres qu'il y
ait plus d'information qu'on ne fasse
pas un travail de fond quand par
ailleurs quand il s'agit de mettre à
l'abri des enfants à la rue on nous
répond qu'au lieu d'ouvrir des places
d'hébergement d'urgence on va créer un
observatoire parce qu'on a besoin de
plus de
chiffres et parce que nous restons dans
cette lancée constructive qui a été
entamée en commission le groupe
écologiste votera bien évidemment
favorablement
laoups la création de cette commission
d'enquête je vous remercie merci madame
la
députée la parole est à Monsieur Pierre
d'éville pour le groupe Gauche démocrate
et républicaine
nupes
[Applaudissements]
madame la Présidente chers et chers
collègues dans une période où le
Parlement se fait marcher dessus à peu
près tous les de jours l'Assemblée
nationale doit avoir l'obsession
d'exister l'obsession de faire ce
pourquoi elle a été élu l'obsession de
ne pas subir l'obsession de faire vivre
tout ce qu'elle peut de démocratie cette
possibilité de commission d'enquête n'y
suffira pas mais elle est au combien
bienvenue en effet en avril 2023 liigas
alerté sur la qualité d'accueil je cite
particulièrement hétérogène dans les
établissements et services d'accueil de
la petite enfance le secteur présentant
des établissements de grande qualité
comme des établissements de qualité très
dégradé fin de citation à ce titre Ligas
rappeler une réalité simple les crèches
doivent être urgemment resitué comme des
lieux en charge des êtres dans une
situation d'extrême vulnérabilité et
dépendance il en va des crèches
finalement comme des épad et il n'est
peut-être pas nécessaire d'attendre de
nouveaux scandales pour réagir les
causes nous les connaissons et elles
produisent malheureusement bien souvent
les mêmes effets les
sous-investissements publics chroniques
et la déréglementation organisée ont
fait la Parbelle au secteur privé
lucrative dont l'exigence de rentabilité
se heurte à une activité dont la nature
première et l'accompagnement le prendre
soin et déjà oui déjà l'éducation
c'est-à-dire un acte qui cadre mal avec
une logique purement marchande si ce
n'est financière et ceci pourtant avec
un très haut niveau de financement
public la pénurie de professionnel est
tout à la fois un symptôme et une
conséquence du désengagement de l'État
dans l'accueil de la petite enfance les
faibles niveaux de rémunération je cite
la qualité de vie au travail le
sentiment de ne pas pouvoir accorder à
l'enfant le temps dont il a besoin ne
permettent pas d'attirer et de fidéliser
le personnel noté également le rapport
de Ligas c'est encore dans ce contexte
que Mathieu Peris en septembre dernier a
publié son ouvrage le prix du berceau
mettant en exerg et interrogeant fort à
propos les modalités de financement de
quatre grands groupes d'entreprises de
crèche et leurs conséquences en matière
de qualité d'accueil la commission
d'enquête présentée par le groupe la
France insoumise s'inscrivait ainsi dans
le droitfil de ces enquêtes et nous
avons été étaent nombreux alors que ces
enquêtes sont parues à souhaité que
notre assemblée se penche sur cette
question en commission les députés du
groupe LR ont souhaité étendre la
commission d'enquête sur le modèle
économique de l'ensemble des crèches
aussi bien publ que privé le sujet n'est
pas le même mais pourquoi pas et à
défaut d'avoir pu avoir ces débats dans
le cadre du PLFSS cette proposition de
résolution permettra de clarifier le
modèle économique des crèches de mettre
en exerg les différences entre un modèle
public et un modèle avisé lucratif
et ses conséquences sur l'accueil des
enfants les conditions de travail des
professionnels et la nature de la
relation contractuelle entre les parents
et le lieu d'accueil de plus cette
commission d'enquête pourra aller plus
loin en matière d'investigation elle
viendra utilement compléter certaines
recommandations formulées par la Mission
flash sur les perspectives d'évolution
de la prise en charge des enfants dans
les crèches qui é un travail déjà
effectué sur lequel il faut
naturellement s'appuyer elle a été
présentée à l'Assemblée nationale en
novembre dernier enfin si le Parlement a
adopté l'article 10 B du projet de loi
dit pour le plein emploi visant à
renforcer le contrôle des crèches il
avait rejeté dans un premier mouvement
l'article 10 qui a été réintroduit
subreptissement en CMP visant à
instaurer un prétendu soi-disant service
public de la petite enfance il n'y avait
pas besoin d'une loi pour mettre le
perroquet sur lesépaule des
collectivités désormais désigné
autorités compétentees en matière
d'accueil de la petite enfance mais sans
aucun dispositif nouveau concernant les
moyens d'un service public ce n'est
c'est donc non pas un service public qui
est créé mais une contrainte sans moyens
qui va mettre le secteur privé en
position de force pour venir vendre ses
produits en disant attention maintenant
la loi vous oblige nous qui défendons
depuis bien longtemps l'idée du service
public de la petite enfance nous pouvons
naturellement tomber dans ce
panneau aussi cette commission d'enquête
est-elle également bienvenu dans ce
contexte nouveau pour les communes
puisque'un certain nombre de
recommandations devront être formulées à
destination des décideurs publics chers
et chers collègues notre assemblée
décidera-t-elle de ne pas enquêter sur
ces enjeux importants qui ne manqueront
pas de ressurgir sur le devant de la
scène de l'actualité dans les temps qui
viennent qui a-t-il à craindre qui
aurait-il à protéger pour notre part
voilà plusieurs mois que nous souhaitons
une commission d'enquête sur le
sujet merci monsieur le député la parole
est à monur groupe liberté indépendant
outre mer et
[Applaudissements]
territoire merci madame la présidente
madame la Présidente de la Commission
monsieur le rapporteur confier son
enfant même à un professionnel de la
petite enfance c'est une étape
suffisamment difficile dans la vie d'un
parent sans que de potentielle
défaillance soit une source d'angoisse
supplémentaire nous sommes aujourd'hui
tous sensibilisés au dysfonctionnement
voire aux scandales qui ont été mis en
lumière au sein de certains
établissements des enquêtes ont été
publiées des travaux ont été menés par
Ligas notamment et je veux saluer
particulièrement le rapport de nos
collègues Peron et Santiago au sein de
la délégation aux droits des enfants
nous partageons les recommandations qui
en découlent pour construire une
politique d'accueil collectif de la
petite enfance centré autour des besoins
fondamentaux de l'enfant à l'exclusion
donc des logiques uniquement financière
néanmoins le sujet est suffisamment
important pour que nous puissions
approfondir davantage les travaux et que
que nous saisissions totalement de nos
pouvoirs de parlementairirees d'autant
que les premières évolutions
législatives si nous les saluons ont été
adoptées dans le cadre du projet de loi
plein emploi autrement dit dans un
véhicule législatif peu adapté ce qui
nous a empêché d'aller plus loin et
d'aborder davantage de sujets comme le
mode de financement le reste à charge
des familles la rémunération et la
formation des professionnels les taux
d'encadrement trop faibles nous ne
sommes pas là pour préjuger des
conclusions de cette commission
d'enquête mais ne soyons pas non plus
naïf oui la financiarisation à l'excès
peut avoir des conséquences sur
l'accueil des enfants sur les conditions
de travail des personnels c'est notre
rôle de parlementaire que de comprendre
à quel point le modèle économique des
établissements a un impact sur l'accueil
et la sécurité de nos enfants notre rôle
est de savoir si un encadrement plus
strict est nécessaire l'objectif n'est
pas de jeter l'eau probre sur le secteur
privé qui dans beaucoup de territoires
pit l'insuffisance des pouvoirs publics
à garantir des places à toutes les
famille mais il nous paraît sain de nous
pencher sur le sujet de la
financiarisation du secteur je ne peux
m'empêcher de faire le parallèle avec
les épad bien sûr nous sommes dans des
situations similaires avec un secteur en
manque de financement pour accueillir
dignement des populations fragiles des
pénuries professionnel et des dérives
liées à la rentabilisation poussée à son
paroxisme c'est évidemment insupportable
et c'est notre responsabilité de
garantir à ces populations vulnérables
les aînés comme les enfants un accueil
dans les meilleures conditions possibles
d'ailleurs lorsqu'il s'est agit de
s'intéresser au scandales Orpa la
commission des affaires sociales de
l'Assemblée national a constitué
plusieurs groupes de travail sur
différents aspects la gestion financière
des épades a été l'un des principaux
axes d'étude et des réponses
législatives ont été apportées dès le
budget de la Sécurité sociale suivant
car elle a été démontrer que le modèle
économique et l'absence de contrôle
laisser la place à des dérives cette
question nous devons nous la poser de la
même manière à l'égard des crèches en
l'occurrence des crèches privées
toutefois nous considérons également que
le sujet est plus large que le seul
secteur privé et qu'il est pertinent
d'ouvrir le périmètre de cette
commission d'enquête à l'ensemble des
établissements quel que soit leur statut
les amendements que nous avons adopté en
commission permettent justement cet
élargissement et répondent aux craintes
des uns et des autres la question de la
qualité de l'accueil des enfants se pose
en effet au sein de toutes les crèches
tout comme le modèle économique je
rappellerai que le mode de financement
est également à interroger pour les
collectivités publiques qui sont
aujourd'hui frileuses à développer une
offre d'accueil pourtant essentiel mais
au coup de fonctionnement parfois
écrasant pour leur budget il semble en
effet utile alors que le gouvernement se
donne pour objectif ambitieux de créer
200000 places à l'horizon 2030 que nous
ayons au préalable analysé précis ment
les équilibres et déséquilibres entre
les différents modèles les différents
statuts de crèche et d'éviter que seul
le secteur privé y réponde et de plus
avec quelles exigences privé public
associatif chacun doit pouvoir trouver
sa place mais avec le même niveau
d'exigence avec la même qualité mes
chers collègues s'il reste encore
beaucoup à faire pour parvenir à créer
un vrai service public de la petite
enfance ne laissant passer aucune
opportunité de le construire dans les
meilleures conditionsib
pour garantir la qualité de l'accueil de
la sécurité de nos enfants et
l'accessibilité à toutes les familles
c'est pourquoi notre groupe soutiendra
la création de cette commission
d'enquête je vous remercie merci
monsieur le
député la parole est à Madame Michelle
Peron pour le groupe
[Applaudissements]
Renaissance madame la
Présidente madame la présidente madame
la présidente de la commission des
affaires sociales monsieur le
rapporteur mes chers collègues en juin
2022 un drame est survenu au sein d'une
crèche à
Lyon suite à cela plusieurs études sont
sorti notamment le rapport de Ligas en
avril
2023 ce rapport fait des constats
particulièrement édifiants de la
situation des modes d'accueil collectif
dans notre pays ce rapport fait état
d'une grande d'hétérogénéités dans la
qualité de l'accueil du jeune enfant au
sein des structures collectives mais
aussi de l'existence de négligence dans
certains
établissements une problématique
importante de pénurie de personnel est
également pointée le gouvernement à la
suite des recommandations de Ligas a
fait des annonces fortes à travers la
création du service public de la petite
enfance en désignant la commune comme
étant l'autorité organisatrice du
secteur acté dans le projet de loi plein
emploi la délégation au droits des
enfants s'est immédiatement saisie du
sujet en lançant des auditions en avril
2023 puis une mission flash j'ai eu
l'honneur de mener cette mission avec ma
collègue Isabelle Santiago pendant un
mois nous avons auditionné un grand
nombre d'acteurs du secteur pour
proposer des solutions concrètes afin de
mener un plan d'urgence au premier plan
l'urgence est d'agir sur la pénurie de
professionnels en effet il manque
aujourd'hui environ 10000 professionnels
pour garantir les places d'accueil
existantes il faut donc au plus vite
mettre en place un plan d'urgence pour
la
formation le mode de financement des
structures est également pointé du doigt
dans le rapport de Ligas nous nous
sommes donc inscrites dans ces
propositions une réforme du financement
est nécessaire l'enfant et son
développement doit être au cœur de nos
préoccupations en effet les solutions
d'accueil ne peuvent s'envisager dans
une vision
unique nous devons envisager cette
problématique par un spectre plus large
avec notamment les congés parentaux les
mode d'accueil dit individuel tout cela
dans l'intérêt unique de
l'enfant le texte qui nous est amené à
être étudié aujourd'hui propose la
création d'une commission d'enquête sur
le modèle économique des crèches et la
qualité de l'accueil des jeunes enfants
au sein de leurs établissements notre
groupe reste persuadé que nous possédons
suffisamment de travaux objectifs et é
certains de nos collègues défendaient
une exigence d'une meilleure qualité
dans les structures en soutien à cette
PPR notamment à travers l'abaissement
des taux d'encadrement ou une réforme du
financement ces recommandations existent
déjà tout d'abord au sein du rapport de
Ligas et la mission flash de la
délégation au droits des enfants rendu
récemment travaillons plutôt ensemble de
manière transpartisane à un texte
législatif pour porter toutes ces
mesures nous n'avons pas besoin des
pouvoir spécifique d'une commission
d'enquête pour mener ce travail commun
sur la qualité de l'accueil cette PPR
cible donc spécifiquement l'aspect
financier des structures notamment privé
si l'on ne peut pas nier que la majorité
des négligences pointées dans les
rapports et livres récents ont eu lieu
dans les structures privées lucratives
cette commission d'enquête nous semble
largement à charge notamment dans son
écriture initiale et son exposé sommaire
je souhaiterais rappeler une phrase que
Sylviane Jino présidente de la branche
enfance du Haut Conseil de la famille
des enfants et de l'âge nous a prononcé
au cours de son audition lors de la
mission flash il n'y a de compétition
entre les différents modes d'accueil
l'un n'est pas meilleur que l'autre le
meilleur mode d'accueil c'est celui qui
est choisi par les parents je maintiens
que la solution est bien de mener une
politique globale du secteur de la
petite enfance en commission des les
affaires sociales notre groupe s'est
opposé à cette commission d'enquête pour
laquelle votre groupe monsieur le
rapporteur n'a une fois de plus pas user
de son droit de tirage cela ne diminue
en rien notre détermination pour
apporter les réponses nécessaires à ces
problématiques malgré l'ouverture du
champ de cette PPR à travers l'ajout des
structures publiques nous restons
persuadés qu'il existe un nombre
suffisant de travaux nous ne souscrivons
pas au caractère d' enquête à charge de
cet exposé sommaire à ce titre le groupe
Renaissance s'opposera à la création de
cette commission d'enquête
merci merci madame la
députée je vous informe que sur le vote
de la proposition de résolution je suis
saisie par le groupe la France insoumise
nouvelle union populaire écologique et
sociale d'une demande de scrutin public
le scrutin est annoncé dans l'enceinte
de l'Assemblée nationale la parole est à
Monsieur Serge müer pour le groupe
[Applaudissements]
nation
merci merci madame la présidente madame
la présidente de la commission des
affaires sociales monsieur le rapporteur
mes chers collègues le récent rapport de
liigas sur la maltraitance dans les
crèches nous montre ce qui ce que ce que
celle-ci semble être devenue
institutionnel pardon ainsi de la crèche
à l'épad aucune qualité d'accueil
correcte n'est garantie aux
Français tout cela témoigne de l'absence
de volonté politique d'Emmanuel Macron
tous les effets délétaires pour nos
enfants ne devrai laisser personne tous
ces effets délitires ne devraient
laisser personne
indifférent personne ne devrait être
indifférent à la maltraitance infantile
et pourtant malgré la nécessité d'agir
vite aucune réponse satisfaisante n'a
été apportée depuis
2017 le rapport dresse en effet le
constat de dérives inaccepable guidé par
de de simples logiques financières qui
concrètement
s'illustre par des privation d'eau
manque de couche manque de gants
commande intentionnellement de repas en
moins pour faire des
économies refus de donner à boire dans
le but de changer plus rarement les
couches en bref
les crèches sont devenues des usines à
bébé des machines àrique pour les
actionnaires toujours dans cette même
quête de rentabilité le rapport fait
état d'une pénurie de professionnel qui
constitue un facteur aggravant autant
qu'un
symptômes le les faibles niveaux de
rémunération la qualité de vie au
travail le sentiment de ne pas pouvoir
accorder à l'enfant le temps dont il a
besoin ne permettent pas d'attirer et de
fidéliser le personnel
au contraire ils le font fuir pour per à
ces problèmes majeurs Marine Le Pen a
proposé des mesures de bon sens qui
devrait être
prioritaire ces mesures ont été mises en
lumière à travers le rapport de
Ligas et je pense et je le pense
par le seront à nouveau à la suite de
ces commission à la suite de cette
commission
d'enquête nous prévoyons d'inscrire dans
dans la convention d'objectif et de
gestion de la branche famille une
trajectoire pour se rapprocher d'un
ratio moyen d'encadrement de trois
enfants par adulte c'est ce qui est fait
dans bon nombre de nos pays voisins et
si ce qui vient d'être mis en place au
Danemark mais en France le taux
d'encadrement est de un professionnel
pour 5 enfants qui ne marchent pas et un
professionnel pour H enfants qui
marchent comment permettre au français
d'avoir un accueil de qualité pour leurs
enfants dans ces
conditions comment leur permettre d'y
déposer leurs enfants serein le matin
avant d'aller travailler toujours dans
cette perspective d'élargissement du
nombre de professionnels nous
considérons qu'il les prioritaire que
l'effectif du personnel de
l'établissement présent auprès des
enfants ne soit inférieur à de et quelle
que soit la taille de
l'établissement afin d'éviter les cas de
maltraitance réguli Marine Le Pen
prévoit également d'instaurer une
fréquence minimale obligatoire pour les
visites de contrôle des établissements
d'accueil du jeune enfant en cas
d'anomalie important de constater nous
imposerons une nouvelle visite dans les
6 mois la fermeté comme mode de
gouvernance et la sanction comme réponse
sont indispensables en matière de
maltraitance
infantile c'est pourquoi nous proposons
également d'accorder au président du
conseil départemental le pouvoir de
prononcer des sanctions progressives à
l'encontre des
établissements quel que soit leur statut
public ou privé beaucoup de choses sont
à mettre en place et je pense à vous
chers collègues de la majorité je vous
invite à rappeler au président de la
République que l'accueil de nos enfants
est une priorité et que les impôts des
Français devrai être investis dans nos
crèches avant d'être investis
massivement dans les centres d'accueil
pour
migrants quoi qu'il en soit une
commission d'enquête sur le sujet nous
paraît bien entendu plus que nécessaire
nous voterons donc en faveur de cette
proposition de résolution je vous
remercie
merci monsieur le
député j'appelle maintenant dans le
texte de la commission l'article unique
de la proposition de
résolution article
unique vous voulez répondre monsieur le
rapporteur allez-y vous avez la
parole merci madame la
Présidente d'abord remercier les groupes
parlementaires qui ont su saisir la main
tendue en commission des affaires
sociales effectivement cette demande de
commission d'enquête a évoluer elle
n'est plus sa rédaction initiale et un
travail transpartisan a été engagé je
suis très heureux d'entendre que
certains l'ont rejoint à l'inverse je
dois avouer être plus surpris d'entendre
certains groupes parlementaires nous
dire que par définition une commission
d'enquête devrait être seulement
partisane parce que réservé au droit de
tirage et de considérer que la
représentation de nationale doit limiter
son initiative parlementaire cela me
paraît une difficulté sur le fond des
arguments qui ont été donnés plusieurs
fois il a été dit que cette commission
d'enquête stigmatisé condamné à l'avance
ou était à charge à l'égard du secteur
privé lucratif chers collègues si
demander des comptes au secteur privé
lucratif c'est une stigmatisation alors
il faut dire que beaucoup de personnes
stigmatisent il y a l'IGAS il y a la DG
CCRF il y a les syndicats du secteur le
snppe et la CGT service à la personne il
y a l'UFC Que Choisir il y a le Haut
Conseil à l'enfance à la famille et au
grand âge bref toute une série d'acteurs
qui nous disent il y a une alerte sur le
modèle économique des entreprise de
crèche alors deux hypothèses soit vous
considérez que tout le monde veut du mal
aux entreprises de crèche ce qui me
paraît assez paranoïque soit autre
hypothèse à laquelle je vous propose de
vous rallier c'est vrai qu'il y a des
signaux qui sont inquiétants et qu'il
est légitime sans condamner à l'avance
mais qu'il est légitime d'enquêter sur
ce modèle économique des entreprises
privées qui gèent des crèches ensuite
vous nous dites à un moment que cette
commission d'enquête peut être
considérée par blessante par les
professionnels du secteur je je crois
qu'il y a un malentendu les principales
organisations syndicales du secteur de
la petite enfance soutiennent cette
commission d'enquête j'ai parlé du snppe
et j'ai parlé de la CGT et pourquoi les
professionnels soutiennent cette
commission d'enquête parce que ell
n'acceptent pas l'idée que la
maltraitance des enfants soit résumé à
une série d'actes individuels de
responsabilités individuelle d'actes
malveillants les professionnel du
secteur attendent que la représentation
nationale mette en lumière le système
économique qui malheureusement pousse à
la maltraitance et donc voter cette
commission d'enquête c'est au contraire
être au côté des professionnels et leur
dire nous voulons travailler avec vous
pour que vous ayez un cadre pour pouvoir
bien faire votre métier et ensuite
dernier argument qui a été évoqué il a
été opposé
la nécessité d'agir c'est-à-dire de
légiférer et la nécessité d'enquêter
alors chers collègues comme cet argument
avait déjà été donné en commission des
affaires sociales je me suis permis de
me de me renseigner j'ai relu très
attentivement le règlement de
l'Assemblée nationale et même notre
Constitution nulle part n'est écrit
qu'il est interdit de voter des projets
de loi dans cet hémicycle et de mener
une commission d'enquête dans la salle
d'un côté bien au contraire et vous
aurez même du mal à considérer votre
rapporteur et son groupe parlementaire
comme ceux qui empêche d'agir parce que
il a été cité le rapport Peron Santiago
qui effectivement formule des
préconisations pour améliorer
l'encadrement des enfants interdire la
suroccupation des crèches améliorer le
niveau de qualification des
professionnels et qu'il serait très
urgent de faire un projet de loi pour
mettre en œuvre ces mesures mais chers
collègues ce rapport n'était pas encore
écrit ces ces recommandations n'étaient
pas encore formulées que déjà moi-même
et mon groupe parlementaire nous posion
des amendements dans le cadre du projet
de loi peine emploi pour mettre en œuvre
exactement ces préconisations et à
l'époque que s'est-il passé la ministre
Berger a donné un avis défavorable et
ces amendement ont été refusé alors je
veux bien entendre chers collègues
macroniste que vous avez changé d'avis
sur la question que maintenant vous
pensez qu'il faut agir très rapidement
et bien faites-le agissez nous ferons
avec vous mais ne nous empêchez pas
d'enquêter sur un secteur qui est encore
extrêmement
opaque et enfin je conclurai mon propos
là-dessus certains nous disent l'avis de
la commission est déjà donné non alors
effectivement votre rapporteur je ne le
cache pas a des convictions sur le
secteur de la petite enfance et la
marchandisation et j'ai même depuis un
an travaillé sur cette question mais le
principe d'une commission d'enquête
c'est qu'elle est composée à la
proportionnelle des groupes de
l'Assemblée nationale et que tous ceux
qui ont des convictions même si ce n'est
pas les même que nous pourrons venir en
débattre et que même une fois que le
rapport sera écrit la commission
d'enquête aura à voter favorablement
pour que ce rapport soit publié donc la
seule chose qui se passera avec cette
commission d'enquête c'est des auditions
c'est un débat argumenté c'est de la
transparence et personne dans cet
hémicycle ne devrait avoir peur de ça je
vous
remercie merci monsieur le
rapporteur mes chers collègues madame la
Présidente de la Commission va prendre
la parole ensuite il y aura trois
amendements ensuite le scrutin et je
suis sûre que pour quelques minutes vous
allez être en capacité de diminuer le
volume
sonore merci allez-y madame la
Présidente merci merci madame la
Présidente mes chers collègues d'abord
un mot sur la forme de cette de cette
commission d'enquête qui est proposée
par la France insoumise finalement cette
commission d'enquête monsieur le
rapporteur vous avez déjà écrit ses
conclusions puisque vous l'avez dit dans
l'exposé des motifs de votre commission
de votre proposition de résolution vous
l'avez dit dans la DG que vous étiez
contre le système privé contre le
secteur privé et que vous vouliez
démontrer à quel point il était nocif
pour faire garder nos enfants la donc
l'intention l'intention et et le contenu
de votre rapport on peut déjà finalement
le connaître à l'avance la commission
des lois a essayé d'atténuer cette
dimension en adoptant les amendements de
Monsieur Bazin mais sur le fond monsieur
le rapporteur votre commission d'enquête
votre proposition de commission enquête
arrive déjà bien trop tard puisque comme
ça a été rappelé par plusieurs de nos
collègues notamment par pine Goulet et
Michel perron il y a un rapport de Ligas
dont vous avez dit vous-même qu'il était
très complet dont vous avez dit
vous-même qu'il détaillait exactement la
situation et les disfonctionnement qui
existe et dont certaines propositions
ont déjà été reprises dans la loi dans
le texte que nous venons de de voter
d'adopter le projet de loi plein emploi
dans son article 10 B qui refonde le
système de contrôle et répond finalement
aux propositions émises par Ligas et
puis le Parlement l'Assemblée nationale
c'est'est aussi immédiatement saisi du
sujet
avec la délégation des droits de
l'enfant présidé par pine Goulet avec la
mission flash rapporté par Michel perron
et par Isabelle Santiago qui ont
également émis des propositions et qui
vous demande plutôt maintenant non pas
de continuer à enquêter mais maintenant
et qui ont émis des propositions très
concrètes pour que nous puissions passer
à l'action donc pour toutes ces raisons
moi je considère qu'il faut rejeter
cette commission d'enquête et que nous
puissions passer à l'action merci madame
la
Présidente nous en venons aux
amendements article unique amendement à
l'article j'ai deux
amendements
monsieur l'amendement numéro 3 monsieur
le
rapporteur
merci madame la Présidente cet
amendement vise à reformuler le
dispositif de la résolution évoquant la
question du lobbying des entreprises de
crèche et c'est l'occasion pour moi
d'évoquer le travail transpartisan qui a
lieu en commission des affaires sociales
parce que en commission des affaires
sociales le caractère transpartisan de
notre démarche n'a pas consisté
simplement à élargir le périmètre de la
commission d'enquête comme cela a été
demandé pour concerner tous les
gestionnaires de crèche mais le travail
transpartisan a consisté également à
reformuler certains alinéas de cette
résolution pour qu'il soit plus
équilibré ça a été notamment le cas de
SEP amendements du groupe les
républicains où le groupe les
républicains considéré et d'une certaine
façon je peux le comprendre que nos
formulations étaient trop accusatoires
envers les entreprises de crèche et bien
nous avons avancé dans le sens de
formulation qui laisse toutes les marges
de manœuvre nécessair à la commission
d'enquête c'est ça le plus important
mais qui présente les choses de façon
son plus équilibré et cela me paraît
positif et cela me paraît correspondre à
une logique transpartisane il restait un
seul point d'achopement sur lequel nous
n'avons pas réussi à nous mettre
d'accord en commission des affaires
sociales c'est sur cette question du
lobbying des entreprises de crèche alors
j'ai pris l'initiative de reformuler à
travers cet amendement l'alinéa pour
qu'il soit plus équilibré je regrette
que le collègue Bazin n'it pas souhaité
travailler avec moi cette nouvelle
formulation mais c'est son droit et il
aura son propre son propre amendement en
tout cas
je ne peux que dire que N nous
souhaitons réaffirmer encore une fois le
caractère équilibré transpartisan de
cette commission
d'enquête merci monsieur le
rapporteur l'amendement numéro 1
monsieur Bazin merci madame la
présidente madame la Présidente de
commission monsieur le rapporteur oui
vous m'avez proposé de de travailler sur
une rédaction commune mais moi je pense
qu'en politique il faut être sincère et
j'allais pas vous faire croire qu'en
travaillant à une rédaction commune
j'allais valider l'ensemble parce que je
le dis on ne savait pas quel serait le
sort de cette commission on le sait pas
ça va dépendre de de nos votes mais je
je persiste malgré les amendements
adoptés vos propos introductifs y
compris à la tribune tout à l'heure
persistent à laisser penser que vous
avez déjà conclu que toute gestion de ce
service par un acteur privé serait en
soi porteur de maltraitance et ça ça me
pose question je pense que vous vous
trompez de cible oui pour enquêter sur
les dysfonctionnements mais pas en
tirant déjà la conclusion que toute
gestion par un acteur privé de ce
service serait porteuse en soi de
maltraitance vous remettez en cause les
délégations de service public et en
faaisant cela vous remettez en cause les
élus qui sont investis et qui sont
soucieux de la qualité de ses services
et qui les
suivent les normes d'encadrement les
conditions d'agrément elles s'appliquent
à la fois aux acteurs privé et public et
donc quand vous dites que le c'est le
modèle économique qui est générateur de
ce dysfonctionnement ce serait le
justifier non les dysfonctionnements peu
importe le statut de ces structures ces
dysfonctionnements sont inadmissibles il
faut les combattre mais mais de viser le
modèle en lui-même c'est à mon avis une
erreur et je pense qu'on doit reprendre
le sujet j'espère que cette commission
ne verra pas le jour sous ce format mais
qu'on puisse y travailler madame la
Présidente de commission de manière à
pouvoir faire en sorte qu'il n'y ait
plus de dysfonctionnement qu'on assure
cette qualité mais pas en en en ayant le
parti prix que toute gestion par un
acteur privé soit problématique parce
que derrière on a des familles on a des
professionnels qui sont impliqués pour
assurer ce service et on a besoin de
tout le monde on a cruellement un besoin
de place dans notre pays et ça passera
par l'implication de tous publ et
privé merci monsieur le député monsieur
le rapporteur vos avis sur ces deux
amendements discussion commune si vous
arrivez à vous faire
entendre merci madame la Présidente
collègue basin vos propos sont
polémiques et
déconnectés du discours que j'ai tenu à
la tribune tout à l'heure et surtout du
dispositif de cette demande de
commission d'enquête je vous ai dit
quelle était mon opinion sur la
marchandisation de la petite enfance
qu'espériez-vous collègu que je fasse
semblant en déposant cette demande de
commission d'enquête de ne plus avoir
d'avis sur le sujet je pense qu'il faut
créer la commission d'enquête et je vous
rappelle je vous remercie de la place
que vous m'accordez dans tout ce
dispositif mais je vous rappelle que je
n'ai pas été nommé rapporteur de cette
commission d'enquête je ne suis que
rapporteur de la proposition de
résolution et qu'ensuite la commission
d'enquête se constituera que encore une
fois elle sera composée à la
proportionnelle des groupes de
l'Assemblée nationale et qu'il faudra
choisir des rapporteurs peut-être des
corapporteurs des présidents de cette
commission d'enquête et qu'elle sera
adoptée à la fin donc moi je dis juste
attention aux au aux arguments qui
peuvent sembler de mauvaise fois parce
que nous sommes ici très observés et
j'espère que personne ne peut contester
qu'il existe dans les crèches dans les
crèches privées lucratives mais aussi
publies et associatifes des
dysfonctionnements qui provoquent la
maltraitance des enfants et si on
considère qu'il y a une maltraitance et
qu'elle n'est inacceptable s'il vous
plaît ne nous trouvons pas d'excuses
pour l'inaction parce que
personnellement c'est vraiment le
sentiment que j'ai quand j'entends
certains arguments donc pour revenir à
cet amendement en lui-même sur cet
amendement je je trouve que cet
amendement par principe
disculpe les entreprises de crèche de
toute forme de lobbying qui dépasserai
la ligne jaune moi j'ai fait une
proposition qui est je pense d'avantage
équilibré donc amendement d' demande de
retrait collègue basin sur votre
amendement et si vous ne le retirez pas
votre contre et j'appelle les
parlementaires à adopter l'amendement du
rapporteur merci merci monsieur le
rapporteur
monsieurazin trs rapidement monsieur le
rapporteur quand vous continuez à parler
de marchandisation alors qu'on a des
acteurs privés qui répondent parfois à
des délégations de service public avec
des cahiers des charges avec des
contrôles mais à un moment vous jetez l'
probre sur l'ensemble d'un secteur sans
nuance et derrière on a des
professionnels de PMI des professionnels
de CAF des des élus qui sont impliqués
et qui assure ce service de qualité je
je vous le dis quand vous vous refusez
mon amendement en disant qu'on disculpe
tout acteur privé c'est pas le cas ayons
une vision plus équilibrée appréhendons
les les choses avec beaucoup plus de
respect pour chacun des acteurs qui
souvent s'inscrivent dans une démarche
vis-à-vis des familles qui ont besoin de
ses places et qui souhaite un accueil de
qualité et je pense que les propos
initiaux ne correspondent pas à la
philosophie qu' peuvent nous rassembler
il faut qu'on y retravaille il y a des
disfonctionnement ne les nions pas
reconnoncez-les reconnoncez-les et
remédions-y mais pas comme vous le
faites merci monsieur le député je mets
au voix à mainlevée l'amendement numéro
3 qui a reçu un avis favorable qui est
pour qui est
contre il est
rejeté amendement numéro 1 VI
défavorable qui est
pour qui est
contre il est
rejeté je mets au voix l'article
unique qui est pour
qui est
contre scrutin
public le scrutin est
ouvert le scrutin est
clos
voici le résultat du scrutin votant 345
exprimé 334 majorité 168 pour 176 contre
158 l'Assemblée nationale a
adopté
am sur le titre amendement numéro 2
c'est le dernier amendement mes chers
collègues amendement numéro 2 monsieur
le rapporteur
rédactionnel
rédactionnel je mets au voix cet
amendement rédactionnel avis favorable
qui est
pour qui est
contre il est
rejeté nous allons maintenant scrutin je
mets au voie la proposition de
résolution merci de bien vouloir
regagner vos
places le scrutin est
ouvert le scrutin est
clos voici le résultat du scrutin votant
349 exprimé 339 majorité 170 pour 178
contre
l'Assemblée nationale a
adopté monsieur le rapporteur vous avez
la
parole merci pron vous entende
simplement quelques mots pour dire que
aujourd'hui la représentation nationale
s'est honorée en se donnant les moyens
de lutter contre les dérives de certains
groupes privés contre la maltraitance
qui existe dans les crèches et
aujourd'hui je pense aux parents qui
sont inquiets à qui nous pouvons dire
nous sommes à vos côtés aux
professionnels qui sont dans la
souffrance à qui nous pouvons dire la
représentation nationale va se battre
avec vous
bravo merci monsieur le
rapporteur la séance est suspendue pour
minutes